du spectacle au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines ce dimanche 11
décembre la structure a accueilli la
deuxième manche de la coupe d'hiver
cette compétition composée de quatre
étapes a été créée cette année par les
clubs franciliens pour soutenir la
formation des cyclistes c'est une des
bases du vélo etc on a un magnifique
bouquet ici que il faut il faut former
des coureurs aie aie aie a pas de
mystère au total 140 concurrents de la
catégorie minimes à la catégorie seniors
se sont affrontés dans les épreuves de
vitesse de sprint et d'endurance sont
sains génial vraiment parce que ça
montre plein l'épreuve du cyclisme et en
plus c'est le club de tennis organise
donc moi je suis heureux et je trouve ça
vraiment très bien c'est une bonne
organisation et je prends ça super
chouette parmi les concurrents des têtes
d'affiché l'un des plus grands espoirs
du cyclisme sur piste mélissandre pain
championne de france du kerry nantes
2015 avait fait le déplacement
je me suis fracturé le poignet ya deux
mois
du coup j'ai été j'ai été deux mois sans
faire de compet et en sans faire de
screen locaux avec le coach on a pensé
que c'était une bonne idée de revenir
courir et de retrouver un peu le la
compétition même si c'était passé va
forcément mais mes épreuves
au niveau international la troisième
manche de cette coupe d'hiver sera
organisé le samedi 21 janvier par le
club de clamart toujours au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines